là le conflit s'est installé dans la
durée oui ça rit sûr et certain poutine
a raté tout y en a raté des jeux le
début de la guerre il croyait que ça
allait se passer en trois jours que les
ukrainiens surtout à l'est au nord et à
l'est c'étaient les amateurs de russie
parlez tous russes et n'attendaient que
d'être côté russe qu'ils allaient sortir
avec avec le pain et le sel est en fait
il se tromper complètement parce que
même s'ils par le russe enfin toute
l'ukraine déjà par le russe a donc fait
là et il a déplacé le problème mais
surtout que
ils ont commencé à décrire une guerre en
fait même tous ceux qui parlaient en
russe à sauf les quelques tarés de
donetsk de lougansk et même la barre ils
sont 10 mai où vous voulez nous aider en
nous bombardant
c'est quoi le délire attendait mais vous
voulez qu'on conçoit rami avec vous et
vous nous bombarder vous nous tuez vous
en cadence est les novices vous nos
villes vont bombarder les civils et les
hôpitaux les maternités cetc c'est quoi
la notion d'amitié
pour vous les russes les russes la
poutine parce que sergei on a vu cette
semaine qui avait un début de
négociation
c'est l'assaut point mort
howie une négociation c'est plus cvc
plus gré de temps côté ukrainien en fait
c'est bizarre parce que je crois que
politiquement poutine il s'en fout
complètement de ces négociations mais
les gens qui sont à la table de
négociation côté ukrainien et même côté
russe finalement ils disent que et
discute des choses que vraiment
importante est vraiment sérieuse et il
ya vraiment un changement par rapport il
ya trois semaines parce qu'il ya trois
semaines medinski quand il est arrivé il
était juste un ultimatum on a huit
points côté russe et point barre et puis
tout le reste ne nous intéresserait là
ça commence à un peu
comme ces non sincèrement ça a commencé
mais en fait je crois que les personnes
qui sont les plus optimistes
actuellement par rapport à l'issue c'est
les gens qui mènent ces pourparlers
parce que même côté ukrainien parce que
côté au kenya ils disent que oui on
arrive à avoir des trucs parce que il ya
des choses parce que dès qu'ils me
disent tu es le territoire dont basse
et la crimée pour le cren c1 de toute
façon c'est niet maintenant il peut plus
même aborder ça mais ils sont ils sont
capables de le mettre de côté et le
crâne par exemple pour eux pour
l'ukraine dont basse tout ça pour eux
c'est ça y est c'est serré c'est peine
perdue ah non non pas de voir ado rien
du tout même pas non pas du tout au
contraire mais c'était peine perdue
peut-être avec la résistance ukrainienne
a fait qu'aujourd'hui le saladier le
même maintenant mais non ils ont prouvé
que depuis trois semaines poutine
n'arrive pas à leur imposer quoi que ce
soit avec soi disant la piste armée
puissante etc et puis les ukrainiens ils
sont positifs ils sont qu'ils sont ils
disent mais on voit les vaincre parce
que en fait le tout c'est que si poutine
n'utilise pas aux larmes
suprême ouais il peut pas vaincre c'est
bien il peut pas gagner il a face à lui
un peuple de 45 millions d'habitants
battus et avis sur le terrain ils
sourient ils sourient ils sont où ils
sont pleins d'énergie ils sont ils sont
ils sont tous là même les femmes
refusent de partir on nous dit ce que
vous nous dites ça nous rassure mais ça
nous fait peur gagne
on voit qu'il escaladait il a dit
que celui c'est à dire un instant sa
première fois que la ville de l'ubs
livres et aimeriez vous barrent
décennale a parlé voilà ce ce matin et
là vous dites sont l'arme nucléaire il
pourra pas gagner cette guerre dont 15
ans déesse qui va pas parce qu'il a il a
nommé il va pas été gelabale clair pour
gagner l'ukraine
le problème c'est qu'on sait pas tout
est absurde et déjà absurde d'attaqué
l'ukraine il a faim il a fait un
discours extrêmement étonnant poutine
hier où il parle de son propre peuple
des russes disant qu'il faut
envoyer son projet sur fonds propres
évoquant
le mot qu'il entrait nationale traître
national très très fermé
sa mort staline quand sergei 1 vous qui
vous pensez que c'est à dire ça y est
vous devez qu'on
en fait hier j'ai changé avec un général
français et là il a dit deux choses
importantes d'abord poutine c'est par un
suicidaire d'accord ça c'est parce que
le mec qui qui émet une table de 5
mètres pour mettre macron à l'autre côté
d'accords d c'est que il craint qu être
empoisonnés et c'est donc il n'est pas
suicidaire un première chose
donc il craint pour sa vie donc on peut
négocier avec lui sur sa vie et ça
allait me tuer moi je dis fille et un
mathieu en rigolant on peut lui assurer
une bonne cellule à la et même même même
de pièces un même les pièces même de
temps en temps un peu de votre temps
voilà donc ça c'est la première chose et
la deuxième chose ce général m'a dit que
dans les régimes comme ça quand ça part
en couilles comme ça c'est l'armée
finalement qui va décider le truc ça
veut dire qu'il y aura des généraux il
ya dix officiers qui ont se dire nous on
en a marre aa nous battre contre nos
frères on en a marre a mené une guerre
qu'ils mènent nulle part sinon amara
est donc en fait s'il ya la possibilité
que ça vienne de l'armée parce que
l'armée c'est quand même un million de
personnes en russie avec plusieurs
plusieurs généraux et ils ont déjà perdu
quatre généraux